sorry i didn't text you back michael
what's that say sorry i didn't text you
back
that's okay you've been busy uh we're
gonna get started
first question tim reynolds
i i don't know where to start the the
way that
either what was what was your favorite
moment either your drive to put you guys
on top for good
or what bam did you know that i figured
that yeah
that seals the game for us and i just
i love how he does any and everything
that you ask him to do
i really do you ask him to pass the ball
he does that scored he does that
come up with a huge defensive stop block
he does that
um he's a huge part to why we're winning
i've been saying it all year long and
i'll repeat it again
he supposed that and he's right a lot of
guys in that moment
i'm not going to get posted like they're
they either whatever
he was not afraid of that and and jason
had him he hit away he had a good run at
him
he definitely did uh we're not worried
about that we understand that in this
league
it happens it happens um but that's a
winning play
you know putting your body on the line
um and rotating the way that he did
we talk about it we go through it over
and over but
bam's been our savior on that end so
many different times throughout the year
ira winterman jimmy can you take us to
your drive when you got the basket
and then the end one fell on jason was
that just a matter of
my ball out of the way i'm going was
that anything that was called or
take us through that sequence please it
was
you know it was a it was a play call i
think it was jay who said a great screen
of
screening his own and then it's just
getting downhill and making a play
you know i think that um my teammates
have the
most faith in me to make a basket or to
make the right pass out of that
and i just saw him i came up with a
bucket
and how important was it for goran to
sort of keep you guys afloat while you
were finding your legs
so that other guys could be positioned
like you when tyler and bam at the end
gore's so smart and he's telling
everybody where to be out there on the
floor
um and he was huge and putting the ball
in the basket he rebounded the ball well
i think he had seven boards tonight huge
um passed it
uh you know he's another one it's kind
of like you really got to guard this guy
if you pay too much attention to him
somebody else is going to do that and
i'm telling you like we got so many guys
that are capable of doing that
anthony chang i know you guys have been
preaching to tyler all season that
there's
more than just scoring uh how impressed
were you with his all-around performance
and i just in his first conference
finals game to finish with a near triple
double
yeah uh that's crazy he yeah yeah
what eleven rebounds nine assists he was
a sixth shot
he's comfortable he's confident and we
continue to tell him to be that way
no matter what game we're in we need you
to play the way he's been preparing for
this moment
all year long um there's nothing that
we're not comfortable with him doing and
he shows up
day after day night after night and you
guys have been dominant late in games in
these playoffs
it continued obviously tonight you guys
were really good late in the fourth
quarter and in overtime what
what is it about those situations that
you think brings the best out of those
out of this team as far as execution uh
i don't think it's just
execution i think we're in really really
really good shape
um you know mentally you know whenever
you're not tired physically
you can concentrate you can remember
plays you can you can do this and you
can do that
we pride ourselves on that and um i
think as of late
we have been playing great basketball
late now we just got to do it for the
for the entire game we've yet to do that
clay ferraro hey jimmy you've been
talking about since
training camp the guys around you and so
we got some dogs on this team and
and yet when they do it in the playoffs
everybody gets to see it
is i i i know you knew this but is there
a level of satisfaction being able to
see them do this
on this stage where everybody else in
the world can see this
not for me no i know what all these guys
bring to the table and how
everybody's ready because their time is
going to come
one minute two minutes 30 seconds all of
our guys are so locked in over there
but they they just work at it they're
comfortable they know that they've been
doing this
so many hours um so many days when the
cameras aren't on when the lights aren't
the brightest
so whenever they come out here it's easy
for them
vince goodwill jimmy you mentioned
earlier about how much faith the team
your teammates having you to make
big plays late what does that mean to
you
just the responsibility of that what is
your mindset you know late in games is
it a sense of calm when you know the
play is going to
you have to make something because of
that faith are you calm about it
of course i think i'm just calling
because i know my role i know what i'm
supposed to do
down the stretch of course suppose
barking at me to
to make a play or to get a bucket
something like that but
i mean my teammates are the same way i
think we do a great job of knowing where
the ball
has to go um who has a mismatch uh
and that's you know the part where
gorham comes in and him saying yo look
this is what we're doing or bam or jay
all the way down the line everybody
knows where the bar should
mark schwartz two for you jimmy
magic johnson tweeted that he thought
bam's block
was the best defensive play he has ever
seen
in the playoffs besides
the actual moment in the game what do
you think would make magic
rule that the number one play he's ever
seen in the playoffs
it was a it was a huge play it was um
you know
obviously coming from him a player of
his caliber he knows
he's been there he's wanted and that's
what it takes to win championships
defense like that
it sealed the game for us and i would
agree with him
i really would i think that what bam did
to save that game
and to to make sure that we win it by
putting his body online
that that really is a really great play
secondly you know not many nba players
would have the audacity to take the
shots
that you took tonight in those moments
they pass the ball off and hope someone
else will get it done
and i know you feel your teammates are
relying on you but
what is it inside you and where have you
come as a player
to be able to step up and make shots
like that against one of the best
defenders in the game
[Music]
do what i'm told to do i think that the
game comes
easy to you uh you take what the game
gives you
and then my my teammates know where i'm
gonna be at on the floor
but the thing is if i don't shoot that
and i pass it my teammates gonna make it
or they're gonna make the right play
that's the way we've played all year
long so
you know it was me tonight next game
it'll be gorn it'll be bam
it'll be tyler he's done it countless
around some time or jay
um it's not just me who does that it's
it's everybody on his team
surat sohi hey jimmy
um from the angle that you had on on
babs block you know tatum looks like
he's pretty much
already there he's got the angle did you
think it was possible for
for him to get there for bab to get
there
here yeah you have to be there bam knew
that
you know we're going into it thinking
you know no threes
so you know you just gotta funnel the
ball
into the paint and bam was there as he's
been countless amount of time for me
for everybody else i promise i'm hurry i
promise you but they want to talk about
you
uh and like i said he saved this and
he's done it countless amounts of time
so i know that he's going to be there
and last question nick friedel
i mean just wanted to follow up on this
quickly through the years you prided
yourself on your confidence
and the ability to deliver no matter the
circumstances
but do you feel like even your
confidence has grown a little bit
in the last couple months especially on
the playoff stage with the way that you
keep
delivering when it matters the most no i
don't think so
i think my confidence in my guys
grows every single second because
they're not scared of anything of any
moment of any team of any shot
um that's what my confidence is i got
all the faith in the world in these guys
to make sure that we have an opportunity
to win and i'm glad i get to be
part of the the leaders that we have
here
thank you for your time tonight mr
butler appreciate it
hi bam
what's up buddy you should start making
donuts
okay you all set bam
y'all ready okay we will start
with ira winderman go ahead ira
ma'am can you please take us through the
sequence on the block on jayson tatum
what you saw when he was coming what was
going through your mind on the play
and was there any concern about a
whistle with the ball being that close
to the rim and where you are sort of
your mindset from when he was coming to
what happened to the aftermath please
thank you
i feel like uh you know play like that i
feel like jimmy knew i was there
and you know he got him to the launching
pad which we teach the whole year
and at that point i had to make a play
so
it's the playoffs and i made a great
play
next is sirad sohi this is
in the play you know you're also you're
also guarding marcus smart for for the
pass in the corner at what point do you
know like i have to get to the rim to
to get to tatum when he took his two
steps and tried to dunk it
i mean uh but
you know it was just i knew my teammates
had my back
and that's we're kind of on the string
so
when i go somebody else got to take my
man and then we just rotate from there
manny navarro hey bam congrats on the
win
i'm curious alonzo morning leave any
messages for you after that block and
what do you think if not what he might
say about the that block
any any help that he might have provided
in the past
check right now no text from zoey
so you're um
gonna tell me keep doing that
but i would rather just not be in that
position at the end of the game
and you know dictated that five seconds
but you know like i said great block it
was a great win
and you know we have one note but we got
three more to get
clay ferraro hey uh bam magic johnson
just tweeted
that's the best defensive play he has
ever seen in a playoff game
when you hear that what does that mean
to you
but uh it's just you know you get on
that big stage you just gotta make big
plays and i
i made a big big play and uh you know
coming from maggot that's a great
that's a great comment from him and just
got to keep
getting better throughout the playoffs
mark medina
eric and jimmy were praising with that
block just your willingness to throw
yourself out there and not be afraid of
you know a poster
what what does it take to have that
mindset and not you know allow that to
be a thing
we were one at that time no we're up to
all right well anyways we were up a
little bit so
at that point was that one yeah
so it's two it's a great flat
but uh at the end of the day man you
just
you gotta make a play uh i did that it's
hard to explain because it happened so
fast for me
um i want a question y'all want to
answer for me uh
instincts i guess mark schwartz
bam it was magic's favorite defensive
play
in the playoffs ever where does it
rank for you as a play that you have
ever made
on any level in basketball and then i
have another for you
number one number one playoffs game on
the line
number one play and
when you actually executed it and you
knocked that shot away
what exactly went through your mind when
you realized
that the clock went to zeros and you had
made that stop
have 1-0 um i get to go rest because
spo tried to tell me i wasn't tired and
i played the whole fourth at overtime
but just the emotion of it tell me about
the emotion um
well my emotions was everywhere but
everybody else around me was happy and
um
this is one of those things you it
doesn't hit you until the game's over
so uh you know when it happened
i was looking at the clock like we still
got time like just go ahead close it out
and
we did that but after that celebrate it
and then
you know we're focused on the next game
now
maggie from etv hi bam congratulations
on the win
um i want to ask you about tyler hero
obviously he had two big threes late in
the game but he was also
one assist shy of a triple double how
much does it help you personally to have
him out there
doing everything grabbing rebounds
assists i know he had the assist to you
on the dunk
this is another element of our team man
you know
at this point you know years don't
matter if you're out there you're out
there to produce
he was producing tonight i'm proud of
him
rodrigo lazarini from brazil
hey ben congrats on win and first of all
uh
how important for you after the win
going to gaming 2 and if you are high
confidence
after the huge
play that you made at the end of game
definitely a confidence booster and you
know
i came into the league as a defender so
it felt like an instinct
and it's a great great game winning
block
and and after and after that and how
how grow like how how your content
growing now after this block uh
that's why it's getting it gives you
more confidence to just
keep trying to block everything and
that's that's pretty much the confidence
right there and then you know
you get a block like that and then feeds
energy into your team
and our last question bam from serato
ego at sarah
hey bam um you know just as a guy who
prides himself on his defense is
anything vindicating about
you know your number one play in your
career so far being
a defensive play
i mean like i said earlier i came into
the league as a defender
and an energy guy so you know just
having that moment it kind of
kind of flashed back to my rookie year
where all i did was play defense and
just provide energy
all right bam thank you for your time
sir well done tonight
last matter people